c'est non non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quoi de plus réconfortant ce siècle
glace est figé engoncé dans son froid
rigorisme que de constater encore
l'exquise sagesse de ses vieux dicton
populaire que nos ancêtres gorgée de vin
rouge et boursouflée d'idées reçues
je t'ai jadis dans l'âtre au coeur
paisible des soirée campagnarde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais direz vous ces vieux dicton n'ont
ils pas pris quelques rides et bien pour
le savoir nous pourrions prendre une
pierre qui rouge et un peu de mousse
mais il ya mieux
eh bien oui le vieux dicton a raison
chihuahua bout du chihuahua foutu
etonnant non
[Musique]